I don't think I've ever really written
about signs I've written about the idea
of sex I guess in its own why everything
is about the idea of sex as much as we
pretend it's not you know everything
you've mentioned Gawker
god it's pretty much all about the idea
of sex but I think it's one of these
things you have to really know what
you're doing and I should clarify
instantly that I don't mean the actual
act itself but when portraying it I
think it's similar to describing war or
love or anything that's been trotted on
you know in literature many many many
times before so you don't sound cliche
so it does sound right for you and
similarly I think those things should be
used judiciously you know unless you're
writing a romance novel in which case
you should probably just take off the
brakes and you know just write about
heaving bosoms until you're blue in the
face but for a normal person writing
anything that's not explicitly about sex
I think it's just very difficult and
I've haven't encountered a reason to
write excessively about
my favorite television show ever
that is tough I'm gonna say it's a tie a
three-way tie hmm
between Twin Peaks the original Wonder
Woman and out-of-this-world you ever
watch that show it's with Evy who's like
half alien and she could freeze time and
I wanted to do that so badly in a
hundred different instances and Athan
you know ninth grade or whatever you
could just stick your fingers together
like like this I don't know if you can
see him freeze time and it was great
because in the opening credits they
would show this sort of power she had in
action and she'd come walking into her
room and she'd opened the door and there
would be a ladder with a bucket of full
of paint on it because that's where you
keep a ladder and a full bucket of paint
is right where the door with the front
doorway opens and she would bump into it
and they showed the paint spell and she
would very quickly do this and it would
stop and it was so funny because it's
like well it is a demonstration of her
powers but the second she undoes that
the paint's gonna spill everywhere it
never made any sense to me but I'm very
nostalgic about that show mostly because
it's kind of an obscure obscure 80s show
but I think enough people remember it
and now I guess it doesn't even really
count I guess the recent past
I loved Arrested Development who didn't
I thought it was genius and now I don't
I don't have TiVo
so TV watching is very difficult I don't
really think I have any favorite shows
that I'm addicted to although I just
because I don't get cable so I live in
like a cave I don't get cable and so I
don't get MTV so I just rented the
second season of the hills I figure from
like tabloids I kind of pieced together
whoever one was and didn't me the first
season but I rented the second season of
the hills it wasn't that good it wasn't
even like that good
you